they went into the brothels and things
like that it was uh
horrendous it was do 30 40 guys a day
and we just have a menu and things like
that
[Music]
beverly looks great
i like the color here it's nice
[Music]
how did you get into this sex industry
it always just seemed like
a job that i would actually enjoy doing
because i'm doing like a fun activity
that i like to do all the time
but then getting paid for that i don't
feel
very strongly about like the social
norms towards like
sleeping around so at first it was kind
of like part-time um
and now i've been doing it full-time for
like
nearly a year well i started in 1999
so it's a long time ago yeah it was just
a
an advert in the paper just saying um
wanted escorts for uh dinners and things
like dinner dates
so i was a bit naive then i got into the
agent's car and he said right we're
going to do the rounds and i went uh
okay what's that then so he said well
you're gonna go see this man this man
this man i went
but i thought it was gonna be dinner and
things like that i was really naive
my legs were absolutely like shaking
like a leaf and he said no you're gonna
see this one this one this one wants
this one
i went oh okay better stop off chemistry
because i ain't got nothing got no
condons on i think you know i ain't got
clue
got in but all the clients that i see
were very really nice
so obviously you come home you've got
all the money but then i got in the bath
i absolutely blabbed everywhere i was
just
absolutely so upset but then i looked to
the mind i thought well at least i can
eat tomorrow
and then i just went on from there yeah
started working for an escort agency
then went into the brothels and things
like that and you know
um it was uh horrendous we used to do 30
40 guys a day
and we just have a menu and things like
that so what we used to do
yeah i think that's the one thing i
haven't done is like have a manager or
an agency
yeah or work in like the same house as
people yeah
um it's harder just because a lot of
people like i've only ever heard bad
things about
those kind of situations so i tend to
stay away from it it was
something that you just fancied or i
didn't think oh god they earned loads of
money or
like that their lives were like really
luxurious or anything it was more just
like
it was more the sex that attracted me to
the sex world oh okay
somebody messaged me saying that he sees
new girls because he makes them feel
very comfortable
sold it to me like he was going to make
the first time like really easy and nice
because he seen that my profile was new
so
we went to the like a nudist bar in
kentucky
i was supposed to be there for an hour
for like x amount of money
uh but then he was giving me like
prosecco and stuff
and then i ended up being there for like
a few hours
and then he didn't pay me until we got
into the train station on the escalator
so i couldn't like get out to counter
and he'd underpaid me as well
and he'd taken like photos of me and
stuff so i've had to like make a real
word i don't take any
clients that don't have any feedback one
of the hardest bits is like the
nervousness and not knowing
how it's going to turn out yeah oh yeah
yeah i'm the same and older you get it
still gets it's just the same
yeah great oh yeah sorry about that
yeah no it's still the same you know
when i go into
you know uh hotels and things i start
shagging
oh my god you know but once you get
through you sort of you okay
i'm here now yeah get on with it you
know
do you ever get men who don't want sex
from you
yeah she's good yeah it's quite good
actually you know
obviously um some of them don't they
want other things
cuddle or something like that or a cup
of tea biscuit or whatever
um but domination i do which is very
mild it's not in
the very strictest thing um
and they obviously don't want sex
because that obviously is part of it
isn't it
i can't think of any time
that somebody's not wanted the sex bear
it's i because i have uh
like advertisers like a submissive
service
so like basically i just i'm there for
them to do whatever they want to do
within reason obviously within
discussing the limits and stuff i have
one guy that uh doesn't have sex because
i think
i think it's to do with him being
married he just
wants to like whip and stuff um did you
not feel frightened about that though do
you not feel
um no you're okay like electrocute
i suppose i have to not be in control
but i like to have my senses about me
which is
totally different it's going back when i
first started you have to have your
senses about you you know
but um i admire you for doing that i i
couldn't do that
i know i couldn't the thing that i would
like not want to do is like drinking out
of a dog bowl and being led around on a
collar like that to me
like i don't like the degrading or like
the humiliation yeah humiliation stuff
i try and offer services that i
genuinely enjoy so that i am having a
good time as well hopefully
there is a part of me that's like
basically performing for them and like
trying to be there like ideal because
that's what we're there for
what's the worst interaction you've had
with the client when i had my own flat
um i had this guy that kept wanting to
come in and see me and it was
silly amount of money it was pathetic
anyways come in i said yes no problem
they've gone into the room and he's uh
he's given me the money
i've gone out put it away gone back in
and there he is standing with his
trousers
and his paints down and these rubber
gloves on
and i'm going okay we didn't discuss
this what's this all about i just didn't
know what it was all about
what do you want to do then so he said
well you know he said you're sort of
like
dirty aren't you well i just hit the
roof i went uh
that you can go there's your money go
really good up my nose yeah because
obviously i'll go to the clinic and
things like that you know and you get
checked out as you do
you have your injections and things like
that so you clean
i thought that was really degrading i
went no
they don't realize that we get tested
and look after ourselves probably
yeah my worst one
was very recently it's like
somebody uh messaged me and he said he
had like a taboo
and then he wanted to um talk about it
on the phone he didn't want to write it
so that was like a red flag i'm like
if you can't have a paper trail of your
taboo then it's definitely illegal
and then he was just like okay fair
enough i searched
his phone number in um some like
databases where we can do like reports
and stuff
and uh there was like four or five
people that had had the conversation
with them he was into bestiality
so he wanted to ask them to have sex
with a dog
i know i was like nobody's gonna do that
with you that's not
insane yeah they just think that like
sex workers must be up for any and then
like it's an okay question to ask and i
was like that's just
insanity uh
what is your relationship like with your
clients over the years
um i do more quality rather than
quantity now i think my oldest one is
87.
you know it's been coming for years but
that's more like um
a friendship and they'll have a
conversation and things like that and
yeah perhaps we do something you know
yeah i've a lot of friends
that used to be clients some of them
will like stay clients
uh so they will still book me for a
specific service
but then like i'll go and hang out with
them at their like comic book shop or
whatever
but they don't tell me that they're mad
at straight away or like in a
relationship
i've tried the dating bit and it it
doesn't work
especially with the job you know it
always like
gets you know too nitty-gritty and like
oh you're doing that with someone else
and you're not doing that with me
and things like that and it's all about
them then you know at the end of the day
yeah
even sometimes they'll pretend like
they're okay with it yeah
i don't think i'm like completely
undateable i just think i don't really
have
that much time to like invest in people
when i spend every single day emailing
with men
that want like so much of like
they just want like the full girlfriend
experience from the get-go so they are
you to tell them all about like your
fantasies and like what you're going to
do to them and all this kind of stuff
and that's exhausting so then to go and
like try and date somebody
and it's not even like the physical
energy it's just like the emotional
energy to like put into people
the guy that i was seeing for like three
years he
just like passed away out of nowhere he
was only like 40 or something
i felt guilty because i felt like i was
holding him back from his life
for the three years that he was with me
because i went to the funeral listening
to like his brother be like oh
he always wanted like a relationship and
kids and stuff like that and it's like
god he invested
the last years of his life and to me
which was obviously going nowhere but
you know at the end of the day that's
good though because that's what he
wanted to do
how has the industry changed during your
career
it's kind of like good and bad because
we're talking more openly about sex work
now that like
people are getting a better view of it
and
not like having all these like horrible
stereotypes about us
we've changed the language up now to
make it more respectful to sex workers
the younger guys would always say um are
you escorting today
are you working today and things like
that yeah it is the older ones that are
like say that i'm whoring
or yeah
but then i just go yeah okay whatever
you want to call it i don't care
what would you say to someone getting
into the sex industry
when you go into it you go into it by
yourself you don't have anyone to tell
you how to do it right or like safely
i made all of the mistakes my first few
times were literally just like stumbling
around
there's a website and it's
safe with two ways i think i would send
them a link to that
tell them to read the entire thing and
then consider
if they still want to get into it like
these are the laws this is how you can
keep yourself safe these are potential
things that can go wrong
before you make the decision uh i think
it's actually
illegal to give uh somebody advice or to
teach them how to do sex work because
it's technically considered managing
them yeah
and that's like pimping so that's i
can't say anything to them actually
just go outside be safe really the
longer that it goes on
the more that i lose faith in the fact
that i'm gonna
have like a job in my chosen industry
um rather than do sex work all the time
but i don't i don't think i'd be that
mad if i was still doing sex work either
keep on girl yeah i mean you know i
should probably still be doing the same
thing
as long as i'm physically able to that's
the main thing anyway
it's lovely to meet you yeah you too and
you take care
right you look after yourself yeah well
take us through your favorite body mods
and tattoos
i suppose my tongue split would be my
mic because that's my first mod so
that's pretty
special yeah and that's like what got me
into it all let's have a look
what did your parents think you were so
young at the time
yeah no they didn't they didn't remind